[Music]
Rorschach's Journal
bit complete now you know what's back
there that's all that is the official
tease for the HBO show Watchmen has
dropped let's check this out
I'm sure Alan Moore approves of this oh
yeah you love that he wrote every
episode this takes place after the movie
right I don't like the same producers
are involved in everything from what I
understand it's a sequel with a
flashback timeline that may involve some
of the original character that Damon
Lindelof described as a remix of the
original material not a sequel or a
remix awesome let's shake it now shall
we
Kingston's cherry I heard clearly
oh damn he's one of the confirmed
returns
Wow so I guess members in his damn I did
not realize that not all of the
characters have been revealed but at
least Jeremy Irons yeah is Adrian Veidt
I'm really hoping that this show is good
and I'm hoping that we can cover this
for YouTube potentially speaking of
which I'm sure you guys like it when we
do this we do TV show reactions stream
along for our patreon page yeah you know
there's a bunch of shows than just some
of the reaction highlights included this
excites me mainly because it's not HP
yeah I feel like HBO has a really high
quality standard of television shows for
a superhero show and not one that's like
a you know generic superhero show
watchman's very different the production
value here looks great the
cinematography looks excellent the cast
gets me very excited for this I love I
know little to nothing about what
they're planning on doing with this
series all I know is that Damon Lindelof
was involved in this who is known to
create quite a mystery and have some
strange kind of storytelling from time
to time and he's also really good at
playing with the bizarre but making it
attainable for the mainstream I feel
honestly mainly the big cell for me is
HBO
yeah yeah yeah
the imagery looks very much like you
know it's inspired by the comic book
panels of the original Watchmen art and
stuff like that I'm curious about this
because Damon Lindelof is a name that
inspired a lot of back and forth I mean
I've heard the leftovers is terrific but
I know a lot of people were not psyched
about his work on Star Trek the overall
impact of lost once it was all said and
done I'm given a hope by the fact that
I've heard so many good things about the
leftovers which is his most recent
series they said that this was supposed
to be some kind of remix and that they
want to bring in certain political
themes of the now because the original
Watchmen comic had so many relevant
political themes from the 60s and stuff
like that they're going to kind of marry
the sensibility to the themes of today
potentially along with the story of you
know this is more dark more practical
take on superheroes and stuff like that
you know you can tell even if Zack
Snyder's adaptation isn't revered as
perfectly understanding the source
material I did think back to that thing
he said recently about like Oh get real
you know you're heroes you know they're
not these sterling individuals that's
kind of part of the bread and butter of
Watchmen is that they are conflicted
characters that they are you know not
just morally correct and there's no
black and or there's no gray area yeah
well I think that's the interesting
thing about doing Watchmen for TV
because I feel like they're I haven't
seen some of the shows that have been
coming out on other networks that are
superhero show adaptations I've seen
enough to make this consensus oh yeah
this doesn't go for all shows but a lot
of times when the series try to explore
or do something different they
eventually start falling in the
superhero trope territory yeah you know
with their TV shows you know it's like
oh we're doing a lot of different kind
of exploration here but then we're
getting that cool superhero action stuff
and Watchmen doesn't really lend itself
to that kind of storytelling I read the
graphic novel the day the movie came out
while waiting in line for a few hours
and then I went into the movie right
away so I don't really remember the
graphic novel all that well but I did
remember going this is so different I
was much younger when I read it
I was like this is all what I expected
yeah and I think HBO can do a great job
I'm not feeling like they have to
conform to that until they gets like
their last couple seasons coming down
and they cut them down into six episodes
each and then they want to just make
them like a big movie and keep them care
more about fanservice and spectacle big
Hollywood action yeah
the Versys is gonna be amazing well yeah
I do hope because Alan Moore kind of
always hates his adaptations like stuff
like this I think watch me is going to
hate this yes I'm sure
and I are they actually try getting Zack
Snyder at initially too and maybe at
least direct the pilot and me involved
creatively throughout this series mud we
turned it down I feel like there's a lot
of potential here and I feel like yeah
I'm with you in the sense that if
anybody can do it I think HBO is a
likely candidate and I like that this is
also gonna be a series and not a feature
movie but you know I still have a
shredded ation because at the end of the
day what I associate with this is like
I'm gonna want a high level of you know
deconstruction and a high level of you
know political sociological intellects
to go into the writing of the show
because I love the tone of this write
this specifically the trailer I really
love the tone of it it feels very
grounded it's not zack snyder helming it
but it is the producers involved of the
Watchmen movie the visual flair here
feels a lot more realistic as opposed to
the movie which is very much yeah Alan
Moore painting being brought to life you
know looking at this like Rorschach cult
at the beginning I'm so fascinated to
know where this is going to be go you
know people inspired by Rorschach like
they don't look like they have the
moving masks that keep changing shape I
mean they have to tone it to a you know
budget the series I thought would have
been cool they actually did the Watchmen
show initially by adapting The Watchmen
graphic novel by just oh the the first
season is just five to six episodes yeah
do a very faithful adaptation of that
and then go into this but I don't know
if that this would complement or match
well with doing that because a lot of
people have argue
or terry gilliam was supposed to do the
watchman annotation or as a miniseries
and I think what's funny is well I know
Watchmen at first wasn't that
well-received the movie but over time
it's really been developing a lot of
love and a lot of people have really
come out to defend and support that film
there's much to appreciate about it even
if it's not a perfectly hewn adaptation
and if it maybe doesn't have all of the
things on the comics mind on its mind
basically but yeah there's a lot I
appreciate about that movie even if I
don't think it's a hundred percent you
know this looks really weird and twisted
and it's open it's actually almost
exactly what I want it to be yeah I
really hope this works out because I
think this could be potentially really
cool and it's like I'm weary about the
idea of straying and Andry mixing the
source material however on the flip side
of that I think that could be really
exciting if they do a good job with it
because yeah we've seen them Watchmen
once the book exists and I feel like
there is a certain amount of like okay
well let's build on this then oh there's
a whole world that lends itself isn't
Watchmen part of DC now - yeah they did
a whole sequel it was day clock which I
didn't really hear much about I don't
know if it's supposed to be super good
or not I feel like if it was great I
would have heard something yeah what's
fascinating to me is DC seems like
they've really been killing it in the
television show Department you know what
happening like Titans was well received
Doom Patrol is insanely well received
you patrol from you know we watch like a
five minute trailer for it because we
were thinking of getting the app and
that was a little more akin to this than
something like Titans where it was like
very heavy on the character x-rays but
even that seemed to be like I haven't
seen the show yet so I can't really
comment on it just from the marketing of
it seem like oh it's eventually gonna go
into like badass superhero territory
yeah where this is gonna be really just
exploration seem like it's trying to
hook you by like being cool and edgy
yeah it seems like it really is gonna
play it straight and the other thing too
is I'll say is like it kind of seems
like it has HBO seen from depending on
like their genre of show like crime
drama elements it seems like it's kind
of hard getting a little bit it feels a
little bit like a detective [ __ ] I don't
know what the word is for it yeah it has
like a tangibility and you got Don John
and you know looking like some kind of
enforcer type character at least and
he's playing a cowboy like character
which is very different for him totally
rarely see him in a cowboy hat really
the thing I'm most excited about is John
as Don Johnson's range just to see him
completely get out of his comfort zone
it's gonna be really awesome Jeremy
Irons - Jeremy Irons going from BBS
injustice league to this other DC show
that's cool which he's not a bad match
for Matthew good in terms of like an
aged Ozymandias no no all right guys
what do you think of this watchmen
trailer comp below you're gonna check
this show out let us know subscribe to
the reject nation click that
notification bell and like button if you
like this video and check us out a
patreon punished